hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's 3 let's get on with night 5
supposedly the last night because I
heard that there is no 6th night to this
game which is going to be very
interesting because I don't think I'm
gonna be able to do 6 at this friend
Bonnie animatronic where any
circumstance thank you and remember to
smile you are the favorite brain here
okay why is it not safe to wear why and
why do I only have two audio checks
perdu that didn't make any sense but I'm
trying not to English here because I
don't speak English good and I don't
English good at all and I don't word
generally and I don't know what oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] no not now I can only assume
missing that one but I know this is a
guest at this point who's just eerie oh
god I'm so screwed I always get screwed
over okay well that's not a good thing
well I seem to be a little bit boned
here because you already on my way to
kill me
so you all listen to the thing I'm
pretty much gonna take this one as a
mulligan because he's already over there
look good for him how about you go over
there hey Logan the cool thing over
there that's a whole bunch of cool stuff
going on over there maybe you want to go
back maybe just maybe
okay cool okay we're just gonna take
that one as a mulligan and pretend like
we actually know what we're doing here
when we're playing this game and I'm
actually finding Mike's gonna keep him
in the same place but I don't know why I
only have two charges goddamn audio
which is a son of a [ __ ] yeah that's me
so on the harder difficulties you only
get one chance I'm guessing when it gets
even harder than this because there
isn't a 9/6 I've heard it's just go
straight into what's called nightmare
mode I can only fathom what lovely
delights await me in nightmare mode I
mean it just sounds like Sunshine's and
rainbows shooting out him a bum bum but
you know to be honest I'm going to
assume that his Scots came here and he
doesn't necessarily want me to have fun
when I'm playing a game he wants me to
be ravaged over and over again and have
my heart palpitated out of my chest so
there's gonna be a hard one and I don't
know what new secrets await me but it's
gonna be take a little bit of doing to
beat I don't want to keep him in eighth
as my oh I didn't know there was a gap
between eight and five since when was
there a gap between eight and five let
me know that did I miss that this whole
time and now I'm at that big of an idiot
how do I miss that how can anyone
possibly be a message but oh hey there's
like no safe point in any of this game
he can be anywhere and you'll always
have an ad Avenu to go wherever the hell
no god damn it no you do not
hahahaha so the best bet would probably
be to immediately put the camera down if
any of the dastardly diabolical other
monsters want to mess with me right now
I don't have time right okay he's over
there let me get him over to here and
then let me just go ahead and slam that
one down so he doesn't have an excuse to
go through there like I've shut this off
this is gonna be very problematic these
audio devices just keep failing on me
cuz if at any moment he gets close to me
then he's I'm done I'm done it he just
gets out of there oh hey oh hey how you
doing boy seems to be a little bit
persistent about me but I don't want him
to be so so a noise and roommate could
also lead them from room 5 is what I'm
gathering here yes I see you over there
Freddie cop demo oh hey why how did he
get here no
I'm dead honor oh crap I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead go over here
what does camera1 do white noise there
I'm in a bit of a tizzy here are the
problems i got problems
it's gonna be a goddamn nightmare that's
it it's gonna be it's gonna be a goddamn
nightmare I'm not oh don't give me a
video we're gonna give me a video and an
audio Erica dammit this is unbelievable
this is incredible how in the [ __ ] am I
supposed to be able to do this where do
you come from where'd you go where'd he
come from cotton-eye Joe hit on me mama
knob Oh get the [ __ ] back there right
now I don't have the patience for you oh
my god all my systems were failing he's
not good Oh goddammit goddammit
goddammit goddammit goddammit goddammit
goddammit where is he where is he just
[ __ ] go go over there
maybe please tell me you were here now I
don't [ __ ] see is that him in the
background over there maybe maybe
goddamnit
okay all you where immediately go [ __ ]
you my dad is I mean I'm dead what does
that mean I don't know what that means
but hey maybe it's a good thing to see
hi-de-hi again go back go back back
demon back back demon back back demon
back so maybe if I make a noise from
camera 5 from here that'll give them at
least a little bit away damn it foxy not
the time for it
not the time I need my audio I need by
audio [ __ ] done now let's have the
ventilation laugh - wait I'll just have
to loosen it for a little bit because I
don't know where the [ __ ] he is
whatever I'm probably dead [ __ ] I can't
even goddamn see I think because I'm so
hyperventilating no never oxygen not
again I don't worries don't always know
I'm always just hoping to God what I
just did that I just did the thing where
you gotta be such a prick my only hope
right now is just to keep him somewhere
in the semblance of - if I can keep him
somewhere in - and I might be ok I think
that's him back there
way behind the thing cuz if that is back
him there we're way behind the thing
then actually that's gonna be ok for me
he's not gonna be too close and there's
no Ven that's gonna immediately to lead
him over there so if he's in the window
to the wall to the sweat drop down ma
foxy I need to get to somewhere that I
can go I don't know where the [ __ ] he is
off anywhere not the time not the time
not the time
I don't worry is hopefully White's just
did that heisted why are you gonna make
me do it again
before am I don't know how the [ __ ] I
made it before I am we friggin breathing
down my neck this whole goddamn time you
get back to that one and then you get
back to three I don't know where the
[ __ ] you are
oh [ __ ] I know ventilation error I know
I'm gonna have a lot of problems real
quick God likes it first fine whatever I
probably didn't need to do that but [ __ ]
I'm an idiot
god dammit I'm such an idiot I'm sorry
for ya
hey ain't gonna survive anymore I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die real soon I
don't know if he's a - you better get
back there
I'm gonna get the gumdrops he's not
there well [ __ ] me ah [ __ ] I'm so boned
so strongly boned I'm boned so strongly
I've got some strong bones in my face
come on come on come on come on I don't
know where he is I don't know I don't
know I don't know I don't know see over
here please tell me he's coming over
there send him in the background over
there
where'd he come from where is he I think
he was on the right what if I can do
this oh hello okay super [ __ ] and
fast
what's all I am no Louisville Asian oh I
just have to guess I just have to guess
from now on
oh [ __ ] me I won't even be able to see
I'm on blind I'm going blind everybody
and I mean not like literally you know
what I meant I hope that works because
if that didn't work the nuts varnished
oh yeah I've never been in such a bloody
panic are just lives a little longer
oh god damn where where is he there he's
there yes I knew you were gonna be there
cuz you were in number two I think I'm
actually gonna be okay because he's in
there let's go take him a second to get
out of the van I'm gonna be able to go I
knew he was in that van because that I
was ready for it because I knew the two
of connect is that particular yes oh
[ __ ] okay that's why he did it I didn't
record time Paul my knowledge of the
system whoa
okay I don't know what this one's gonna
be this know the characters left to play
oh no on the crying child oh why am I
the crank I was in like a sheer panic
for the last three minutes there so
don't blame me for being a little bit
over Oh
oh man my heart is pounding out of my
chest and don't feel good what are you
doing even purple Freddy isn't here to
guide me saying to follow him there's no
shadow Bonnie there's no nothing the
whole lot of nothing's anything I can't
deviate from the path on this one oh man
I don't know what the purpose of this is
the fan isn't even spinning anymore this
is all alone here completely alone and
isolated
I don't know why I don't even know what
this thing represents I mean I know that
the whole story of five nights at
freddys said children were brutally
murdered but to be honest I don't know
if that's actually literally represented
in what this character was because his
character was from five nights at
Freddy's 2 in the cutscenes that were
kind of like this oh boy well that don't
look good but at least there's cupcake
in the middle of there oh man oh man
what do you got for me can I actually go
through oh hi what are you doing what do
I do
you look a little surprised but there's
a bunny there's a spring-trap uh you
look who's a minigame out of force you
in that suit you [ __ ] you get in that
goddamn suit I will make you I will god
that makes ago that goddess oh oh oh
that's how oh that's not good oh no you
laugh at me oh oh oh it wasn't her it
was purple guy what bad ending what do
you mean bad ending how do you get the
good ending I didn't know there were
multiple endings to this house I
supposed to know that you gotta be
kidding me how is that the bad ending
what did I need to do to not do the bad
ending why
extra oh hey oh holy cow hey how's it
going there foxy looking good loon boy
phantom chica phantom Freddy looked a
lot like golden Freddy The Phantom
puppet Jesus mini-games
oh I haven't unlocked him Oh Oh God your
feet are so weird - okay okay so I don't
know if I did something wrong there I
thought I did everything right unless I
didn't play the minigames correctly I
don't know I really don't know okay so
that's gonna save for another episode
there's actually more of the story
available in nightmare mode and I think
I can beat it like I think I can
legitimately beat it if I know exactly
where to go I'm betting I only have one
audio cue and only a little bit of
camera time and a little bit of
ventilation but to be honest I can
actually know where he is if he's in a
certain spot especially if he's in that
two area then I think I'd be okay so
let's just find out either way thank you
everybody so much for watching get ready
for nightmare mode I don't know how long
it's gonna take me to beat it but I'm
gonna try damn it so thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
why the hell do I need to do that
I didn't move
mother of God I'm the king
I gotta